[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody good morning happy
Monday how's it going purged here
Ritchie is joining me morning and yeah
as you can tell by the title we're gonna
be playing some tin chew stealth
assassins little Ritchie is he's gonna
hold it down but you know while we let
everyone you know get their breakfast
together and join in exactly we are just
gonna have a little chat enjoy some of
this some of these tunes oh yeah yeah
it's Monday and we are definitely gonna
get to the game we've got the timer
right there on the screen for you guys
but while everyone starts piling in you
wanna you know take this time at the
beginning of our live streams you have a
chat see how you guys are doing and also
talk about some cool stuff we've got
going on
[Music]
and of course we have a ton of content
on the YouTube channel as well not just
our live streams which are usually every
morning at 11 a.m.
we're behind today but we wanted to get
this awesome game prepared and ready for
you guys which we did but anywho um
recently we posted this awesome article
which I'm including in the chat right
now of games that everyone here in the
office has been playing and I think it's
kind of cool because we always are
reporting news on new things and new
games and all the hotness but you know
we're playing things behind the scenes
on our own time as well and yeah it's
not always the latest greatest yeah
example today exactly exactly and the
list is pretty cool and we were kind of
disgusting like games we've been playing
recently too and you know we got a lot
of awesome things on this guy destiny to
like help still says always I'm always
playing destiny too and some really cool
is that I actually haven't even heard of
like Michael hi I'm playing The Legend
of Heroes trails of cold steel - I've
never heard that but the picture looks
really cool so yeah these are all of our
GameSpot staff like our editors and
video producers David here is playing a
more DBZ Kakarot yeah and I saw
yesterday he tweeted he got all the
achievements unlocked for the game and
he's like alright I'm done now guys so
what about you guys in the chat right
now where do you guys playing right now
and please give that article a little
look-see because there's way more than
the things that we've just mentioned on
this list and shout out some at Espen le
he's saying he's playing some Dino
Crisis yep like yeah I might have
sparked the fire for that because I'm
working on a video about games that need
a comeback game series that need to come
back and me and Matt we're talking about
Dino crisis we threw it on the list yeah
and he has good memories with that game
as I do so I think like we were talking
about he's like I wanna go home and play
and I was like I do too
I don't have it anymore but he
still has his copy who's flexing I mean
we are actually playing the ps1 look at
this look at this jewel case
[Laughter]
Malati I'm sorry if I said that wrong in
the chat says I'm playing ninokuni yeah
cool I know I was actually definitely
about to go replay that again because
I'm PS now oh I like 208 wants a remake
of this game no one does more than me
although people have always you know
been like the spiritual successors have
been these like these these newer games
even like like all these blood-borne
games and sec yo stuff you know same
sort of style but i want to remake of
this with the name in it yeah let's see
drag yo says stuck getting trophies on
jedi fall in order
oh we know that grind man oh yeah
Gabriel says I got that one tint you two
is more fun but this one is great super
hard interesting well you know what
I played tent you to like way too late
in life I loved one so much and I
cherish it it's like one of my personal
favorite games and then maybe like maybe
like ten years ago I finally picked up
ten g2 and like I was like okay it's
good it's a prequel but it's not it
doesn't touch one for me
I feel eeeh aspilia we got some throw
bag we got some memories of this game in
the chat - of course I mean this game
came out what 1998 I'm sure there's
plenty I was there when it launched I
was probably a little too young to be
playing this m-rated game but uh we had
a burn copy I think jeez I don't
remember I remember if it was mine I
went out and bought it yes you know back
in the day where we actually has a rally
site
honestly I would go to some of the cases
of the newer games just to see if we're
gonna run into a little bit late oh my
god they don't make them anymore this
was one of my first eBay purchase whoo
for hints and tips on Activision games
call one nine hundred at six eight zero
hint
Oh $0.99 permanent hid a hint hotline so
that was the thing back then I never
called them as I knew they they'd rack
up the phone bill we got some memories
of ten choosey for the 360 yeah played
that one too the series sort of fell off
this was considered in the list of my
games that need to come back this is a
strong contender but in so many ways
it's been sort of remade but you know
I'm not even sure if it'll be on the
final list but yeah you guys I mean we
are all obviously playing games on our
own time but we are also making a lot of
content here for you guys on this
channel and on the website and like
she's mentioning before like we have
these ideas in the works and that
content coming to life so of course if
you guys have missed out on some recent
you know content and videos that we've
done we've done some cool apex related
guides for the new character and
revenant we also have the after-dark
podcast where they talk about all kinds
about the most recent episode was just
three days ago
they talk about persona 5 scramble birds
of prey apex legends so
yeah we've got a lot of stuff going on
it's pretty cool so yeah ten - I love
you
Marcello says from Wayne Ape Escape has
been forgotten
I love Ape Escape that brings like
strong memories of like early
PlayStation days not that early because
it was actually the first dual shot game
where the DualShock was launched I
remember that good times the soundtrack
all those sound effects on everything
just brings you back really far for that
game same with this game especially
although this game I try to play like
every year or every other year it's just
pretty short game but I love it so much
like it's like you know when you're out
trying all these new special drinks and
sodas and you're like but at the end of
the day I just need me some water some
water you need it whatever the champion
Kevin says best ninja game well we're
closing in on our last morning chat time
like I mentioned before we got last up
going on so make sure you're tuned in
games by comm tune in right here on the
channel we are going live every single
weekday morning yep
11 a.m. Pacific time we're a little lazy
that's okay it's Monday we gotta do that
darshan says thanks for streaming this
game you are oh my god you are welcome
thank you for being here thank you for
being this is like a personal highlight
of my GameSpot careers being able to
play this on stream like what you guys
you want me to do that heck yeah are you
kidding me yes I mean honestly I've been
enjoying listen to these tunes while
chatting with you guys
so I'm excited it's so good oh my god
alright
any final final thoughts on this Monday
morning at noon I'm just reading the
chat now I'm into it I don't even know
you and I love you for doing this right
here we go
stridor got it straighter sub if you
aren't because to the big time I'm gonna
get the controller ready boom boom boom
boom
I'm excited alright so let's do an it
perfectly went to the title screen like
right here they did it like ended and it
landed right back here at the beginning
all right let's do this
alright John I'm gonna bump the volume
just a little go for it because I feel
like we are in how ahead of its time it
let you pick right very select screen
for a like a single-player ninja game
right so just a purchase cool chick well
you know red soldier you're cool I don't
know if you are a chick or a dude but
you're just cool anyways thanks for
being here yes don't skip cutscenes ooh
everyone wants to bully reminisce ok I'm
with it here we go listen to this
beautiful character wealth is one thing
current status is another minion
emergent class have become rich but the
merchant class is a large step below
nobility merchants no matter how wealthy
cannot become samurai this caused many
merchants to lust for the power they
were officially denied a few more so
than a man named Mitchie Goya
The Jackal had began his career as an
illustrator but before long his rivals
began to turn up dead and itchy go ahead
expanded into protection loan sharking
and gambling
his methods are brutal his profit fast
if arrested itchy Goya would simply
bribe his way free you must make him pay
for his crimes with his life here we go
camping with his life you know what I
don't need any of this this pic before
the game before the level I don't need
it okay it's gonna jump like I'm pro I
don't need this here we go time to
punish say break man said this game
releases my inner samurai heck yeah dude
me too I don't know do you guys think I
should play like on the radar and just
kill everyone or should I be stealthy
maybe I'll go back and forth between the
levels because the kills are a sight to
be seen like you can mess people up in
some funny ways but you can just go
around music to meet the soundtrack is
one of the best parts that's why I
didn't like too nearly as much because
it was there was less music you can't
take that away you can't it was the best
one of the best parts of this original
game let's wit chameleon oh man the
memories it took me and my brother a
month's visa
nothing I'm going for 90 minutes baby
are there some speedruns can't take it
you cannot harm them thank goodness
check this out this is the first
cutscene you guys are gonna probably
remember this as much as I do that's the
bathroom slice them up here I come what
who are you I'm here to avenge all the
innocent people you've hurt somebody
help
get him gets him it looks like you chose
the wrong party to crash she's making
these dances with Ichigo yeeah step
aside or I will have to kill you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
and she go yeah clap you mean spotlights
hey well he's like for you too right
back at you Frank thank you get the F
out of here I'm sorry we have to you
know
slice and dice real quick that cat sees
me I'm out of here
it's gonna blow my cover I love their
conversations there aren't many in this
game but the guards talk every now and
then he was just like nice Brandon says
this game looks like sekhuru right this
is like definitely inspired from let's
see
so now Ichigo yeah the big guy got away
that's time to find him and I might flub
this jump got my grappling hook me up
real this is like him sake arose like
poured into the ps1 right no way man
this came first
yeah exactly Sakura looks like this game
Oh wrong door oops card like when CD
games were like the new thing they made
like all these Redbook audio tracks and
like the best soundtracks they've really
put time into them all that guy okay I
think that guy's standing right in front
of the door I need to be in so you know
know it for the chat but someone else
sometimes no sometimes it happens well
your bodyguards are dead and you are
next here we go
he's got a gun word yeah
oh I don't have one I didn't pick up the
bomb your greed sickens me I hope your
death is a lesson to others well the
best ranking you can get is grand new
okay I'm one below like the top of the
line get brand new to get a little bonus
prize it's okay I am thank you well I
went about that the quickest way
possible maybe I should slow down cool
flavio says in the chat I hear somewhere
that Sakura was first imagined as a tint
shoe sequel but evolves beyond believe
it would laws and tends to attack Lord
ghosts don't want a copy of their plans
if these plans are delivered to lord
gohda his forces will crush the outlaws
at little cost without the plans lord
gohda faces a brutal fight the enemy has
sent a group of ninja to the town or
destroy these enemies and get the plans
to lord gohda that's our damn right
there he's them the lord of the azuma
ninja clan which is my my ninja clan
thanks classically trained I'm seeing
lots of ghosts of Tsushima attack yeah
in the chat oh my gosh yes I didn't get
Grand Master or Foxhound rank yeah I
know
Fox ranked you funny Iroquois Plissken
in the chat from Metal Gear Lord goood I
sense danger oh damn I just pulled up
I'd even like oh well I mean what did I
expect like a helicopter landing
[Music]
here we go that's like one of my
favorite cheese's this Maps a little
tougher because there are enemies second
jump up on the roof with you or some out
some that hang out on the roof I don't
know like it's um I'm wondering what
play style I should go for do I go for
Grand Master or just like you know kill
everyone because that's a fun way to of
course all right there's one death from
a danger with it I was ready to block
[Music]
this will take more time and I'm gonna
get a lower ring see that was my opening
dang
[Music]
couple slices Oh No then everybody else
so far what's this ball dough over here
if it fizzles out maybe like that
sometimes he waited for it all right
enough messing around probably pick that
up again and the music's back didn't it
all right you know what yeah recycling
we recycle you're telling a champ Oh any
drier oh well you guys that's a little
memory of the gameplay maybe I should
just go back on the roof
[Music]
don't blow my cover kitty I'm out oh
she's coming up
[Music]
paced ghost says I've been wishing for a
new Tinchy for the longest time
- Jonathan em also acknowledging the
nice music I'm seeing they really put
that extra bit of love into the
soundtracks cool I'm losing them oh
there's an innocent never harm the
innocent no I just can't make that jump
wait don't look at me lady I wasn't here
you're a dog
I'm just blowing my cover all right my
clothes there's the river
that means the bridges oh you know what
they can't swim I can sew oh yeah rock
and a hard place struggling right now
joining the best
great see the perks of knowing how to
swim nice that's the end right here
though you know you can do that level in
one minute but I was around
please forgive my late arrival Wow if
you get there fast he's waiting for you
come alright time to meet the Big Cheese
look at that novice the samurai hands
yeah that was for you Chad I want you to
like I can just you know pile through
this game but we don't want this dream
to end that quickly plus I'm not like
yeah what's the speedrun time on this
game yeah we gotta check like YouTube
let's see I shall research cyborg man
they live on an island how can they not
swim I don't know man Jonathan M says I
love the grappling hook heck yeah these
loading times give us time to talk chat
what's up I sense danger though I'd best
hurry I just did this mission didn't I I
did like a bat speed running speed
running
I'll just be seeing I'm just gonna run
oh alright
so on speed run dock oh my god here we
go the first ring is from a player
called ninja QK and he is from the
United States it says real time 25
minutes 59 seconds oh my god
in-game time 11 minutes and 27 seconds
what oh my gosh okay because they take
out all the cuts and stuff yeah I think
so whoa well I don't know how I got to
replay that was so close to the end all
three of them jumped me you missed at
least for like I don't know I don't know
how I did that level over again but
that's why I just ran through it a
second time let's ignore that oh you
know what I did I hit retry at that
screen instead of poops like carry on or
whatever rats
blast from the past that is correct
walrus heck yeah you know we were
inspired by our list on the website of
all the people in our office and what
they're playing right now that is
captured well underclass Colossus miss
you guys in a torture chamber deep under
a dangerous forest with orders to
immediately flew the cat
lord gohda has released you from the
ninja code which forbids rescues you
must free the captive and quickly who
okay well I remember this cave level
very well kind of stinks but I haven't
used these yet these little disguises
they rule so I might use one for this
level let's go do it man there are bears
in this level oh there are pitfalls you
guys might beware of wild beasts Ben
bears
oh snap the forest uh you know it's oh I
see yeah I just see them there's a big
old tree oh it I thought it was a bear
it's actually just about oh there's like
the foam the final boss at this level
he's got like a human oh my G oh said in
the chatter Ichi can you guys please try
Syphon Filter next boy literally we're
gonna play that today instead of this
that's so crazy thank you mention that
Jo all right this guy's gotta go back it
up got him
but yeah I wanted to play Syphon Filter
by PlayStation 3 at home has it
downloaded try to download it here it's
like you got it on download it at home
first share these games with people
that's what they think is going on
my goodness wack I wanted to play that
this morning this is like gosh these are
tied for some of my favorite PlayStation
games though so nothing wrong with
playing with this game I do out chillin
right
no bathroom or anything okay there are
wolves and I don't want to hurt them so
I'm just going back in the cage cuz they
hurt you oh here we go
[Music]
got him there are other ways to like
assassinate him but it's all based on
the directional pad like if you press
right and the action button they'll do a
different kill move just check in my
surroundings David in the chat David
streaming since you stealth assassins
wash and check out your channel where
often in my opinion one of the best
games of the ps1 way too many people
didn't play it hey man oh I'm just too
close to a wall there's a dog who saw
the whole thing look I'm out of here
maybe I'm toast nope I missed it I just
stood there like an idiot I got hit yeah
this is a throwback Ian for sure we
always try to play the latest grades but
every now and then you know we're
playing this because of our game smart
articles are more something
that dog is after me I hear him still
sometimes thanks oh no I'm not getting
lost that way this is the way you know
oh yeah
question commander James Shepherd which
who asks what games have you guys been
catching up on the throwback season I do
have a long backlog but I've still just
been stuck on Cod what about you well I
finally got three more of the Kingdom
Hearts DLC mmm
now I don't know if you mean throw it
back as in like retro games or just
games that have already been released
that we have had champion but you know
on both ends there I will say my
throwback throwback has been found nc7
because you do play that since the
remake hype is coming and you know I
started playing the original a couple of
months ago and I took a break so getting
through that in celebration and then
Neuer that isn't retro friendly like I
said got to the Kino heights weary mind
DLC yeah
it finally happened like power up
together are you we got help
alright well I threw my over here not
going for stealth in this level there's
no way yes well there is hammer was like
hey you guys know you're supposed to be
stealthy yeah there's a way to pull it
off can you grappling like enemies asked
Walter no I'll try I'll show you but I'd
be like some pathfinders that would oh
there's a pit here probably would a
draconian said my very first PlayStation
came with this and Silent Hill Wow yeah
alright
well that's locked what's your favorite
RPG franchise or to be fair top three I
feel like there's a lot to choose from
here I'm within a Star Ocean honest and
to be fair I don't I have not played a
lot a lot of RPGs seem here with you oh
oh nice let's play head thank you oh
yeah what about you guys Calvin in the
chat hell yeah the nostalgia is strong
yeah oh snap
wrong way in the chat Star Ocean is my
favorite oh there's a guy back there
somewhere I heard someone talking oh you
know another one I liked and I liked it
because there's actually a lot of guns
in it is resonance of fate Nami it's I
randomly stumbled upon it because my
friend played and I was like this is so
cool and it's like guns and all this
crazy stuff and you can like customize
your characters and they do the whole
thing where they add all your
customizations to cutscenes and stuff
like that and I'm just a sucker for all
of that so I really love that game you
know what you like
I think it's bear time Hello Kitty my
Island Adventure I've never heard of
that but I already immediately want to
play it right now what is this guy going
excuse me j-bird I've been catching up
on the yeah sorry anyone
I say use it like that but number four
now tomorrow is it favorite ninja game
are you telling us or asking okay
there are no bears this time sometimes
there are two bears but I think there
oh there's a bear okay nope there's my
friend I gotta save resonance of fate is
hard when I the first time I ever
started my smile you like
slightly getting wailed on they made it
look like you died right there but you
didn't oh my god what do you know he
finished falling down okay yeah so the
first time I ever started my resident
resonance of fate game you run into like
a pack of dogs or wolves or something
right at the beginning and you know
they're like low-level just regular flip
enemies they destroyed me and you have
three people on your team and I just I
got I don't watch much South Park I've
seen like old school episode of I
haven't seen anything recent or new oh
that scared me
I was gonna lose die in peace you
misguided soul
[Music]
you know what amazes me about this is
that you took your time they're like
limitations graphically yes they still
made all the characters look very
distinct and unlike stylistic in some
ways oh absolutely
ninja do you want to try a little I do
not because I feel like when else ever
we're gonna be able to stream this and I
went the viewers have the best gameplay
of possible when we play tenth of heaven
mmm those are two different games I
think I'm not sure maybe the fragile
troops only cog a it's like in Street
Fighter is Oni and cogs really there's
like two characters like one followed by
own suppose that guy kicks in a wash and
that's his move as the king he doesn't
even have a weapon Lord his feet are his
yes this neighbor intends to attack with
an army of 20,000 member this level lord
gohda must be informed you rush back
towards his territory under the cover of
darkness norm not who do you come across
an enemy checkpoint there was no way
Simon ya need a checkpoint ten shoes he
was on 360 I think here we go sorry I
talked a little through dad but the
choice is so monotone and like I was
like oh wait he's speaking he was
clearly talking for at least three
sentences Kareem says thank you for
bringing back my childhood oh my
pleasure
you know it's nice to revisit these
games sometimes because you know kind of
shows like where we came from in the
inspiration behind some of the really
popular games now you seem to be in
great haste for such a late hour
ah where are you going the night is no
time for a woman to be trained excuse
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah those are fighting words let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes he almost did I almost failed you
were a skilled and honorable opponent
yeah they denied you the chance to be a
happy Wow what's all I need to do is
make it to the other side she's
extraordinary okay we get that out of
the way oh man disrespects well I
probably shouldn't gone through the
front doors like that but there's gonna
be a lot of heat on me now oh yeah fully
functional looks like nice night
oh nice night Simon Says I used to play
this on my chip PlayStation I had to
turn the PlayStation upside down for it
so you must have had a model one this
was back when you had to get real
creative on ways to get certain things
to work correctly right side work me any
strain of just murdered her for training
she was the gardener bro being a savage
straight savage and you have to deal
with his with her brother later on he's
the gardener other side [ __ ] he saw me
oh wow yo Oh
[Music]
come on sometimes you can hit them into
the fire and it's the greatest thing Oh
God Oh Oh air combo yo enough so good
you didn't see anything dog I'm out of
here I probably should have taken the
bridge either that's like the worst way
to be seen you were saying do I want to
go for a stealth kill wish me luck
I know what to do oh never mind I don't
have it equipped there's a little
disguised thing you can use but I didn't
equip it someone's onto me oh if there
are two exclamation points on the bottom
he saw me there's one thanks you saw me
it's turned around I'm gonna go purchase
let's go go Beltran ah well I got him
but I didn't do that you know the
cinematic killer was having the most
epic death sequence rip to that guy see
who has seen me someone's like what that
was me earlier
oh yeah indigo bolus wasn't there a
lock-on button not in this game that I'm
aware of what did i do it it I broke it
some of his joints and then he started
bleeding out well that's fine with me
he's out of my way okay there's a guy
down there no my son he just had a turn
around huh that guard was so extra so
the chameleon man they're all dying so
dramatically okay quit blaming me kill
you oh great
I feel like there are a lot of things I
remember playing back in the game but I
have no idea what they are like I don't
remember what they were called I just
remember bits and pieces of it and I'll
try to go in Google live by the small
bit of information
I can never find it he killed his friend
I'm sorry oh nice you know a little
teamwork yo this guy's gotta go that
happens sometimes though they can they
can fight each other or hurt each other
by mistake I'm kidding I'm getting
stabbed I just you know no matter if you
don't kill those guys though I might
want to see this man if you don't kill
those guys though they they get involved
in the in the final boss fight like
you're fighting him and then they keep
oh that's smart though because that's
how it would really be yes oh wow
everything Twinkletoes this is
ridiculous you die Mike Wellington Sam
Road this is a classic this guy is 20
years old okay cool I was awesome
got him oh hey what are you doing hey
yeah
nah we dodged that get your arrows out
of here I'm getting surrounded I hear
him
Oh Oh keno yo Ibuki says OMG my favorite
game of all time heck yeah man this is
in my top 5 I'm so glad you guys not
only are here to watch but happen to be
available to see that we were streaming
this and then be like oh snap
yeah this worked out this morning
indigo already God now I feel old liquor
chameleon don't tell me ok after this
guy I'm going for the boss
[Music]
thank goodness yeah
is there anything up here I can pick up
before the boss fight sometimes am i
doing must use my gotta flex the the
backflip man
maybe not sometimes I don't even feel
like there's a bomb up there I could use
that to to bombs
smoke them out and blow them up pick it
up I'll prepare a smoke bomb are you
ready time to face yes that girl's
brother please forgive my sister was a
brave woman I am in a hurry to return to
my master I ask that you let me pass
like you I own what a brother team My
Orders are to detain you
I am sensual Akashi master of neo Jean
saga style source man ship and worst
brother ever write this humility and
honor man a stranger clan I fully accept
your challenge commence comments prepare
to die
homeboy yeah smoke down can't see me too
close okay you there I almost got the
three-piece get up get up and face me
Wow where is your honor and nobility
[Laughter]
you can't get him on the ground no kick
got him that's to your sister put up a
better face
[Laughter]
thanks dude he was nice you are a master
swordsman and an honorable man it is a
shame we could not fight as allies who
ever did a flip over his body
am i that sorry though yep might as well
kick dust in his face the dark souls of
ps1 I don't know I was thinking about
that I was like okay is this game really
hard like or or do I just play too much
and I don't find it that hard anymore I
don't know what the you know when you
first played this when you're younger
you're not as skilled of a game right
now so it's true a little bit of
everything I play Lord go I like this
level of mr. kataoka is abusing his
position accepting bribes and return for
assigning city construction projects and
similar favor there's some
funny voice acting coming out of the air
the son-in-law of Secchia one of Lord go
to his most trusted advisors lord gohda
knows the truth and could have Kotoka
arrested but does not want to bring
unbearable shame hmm understanding his
master's dilemma acequia has decided to
resolve the matter himself and orders
you to execute Ratliff's cramming
rikimaru is so honorable glad you're
still here Gramp Gramp Gramp he was here
early in the Chai's like I don't know
man this is gonna be nice games great
gameplay I decided to look up some more
it goes to Tsushima stuff some two bags
are talking about it because I was like
yeah I mean I only remember seeing the
trailer bomb look at some of the
pictures now and it's really pretty
pretty we're getting a suggestion from
chat to put our little window on the top
of the screen with a helpful yeah maybe
yeah cuz uh I'm at the bottom in the
middle of a fight I'm at the mall we got
you what is this bazinga yes this level
is so good snowfall taken bribes what
happened to Korea
oh yeah we wasted that red line
we sound like beavis and butt-head
oh there's a guy alright I might go the
sneaky route these guys are a little
tougher okay
then before here we go I'm just gonna
chill here
[Music]
right they went in they gave every stage
like a nice fitting unique individual
song so good right like cuz this is like
a snowy stage it does feel a little more
winds like you know winter whimsy yeah
but still very much epic yes like I
still feel like yeah I could slice
someone open to this
I might have to in a minute yeah okay
there's one little guard I gotta find
first he looks like that guy but he's
hanging out by a tree he's like I get
close to killing him and then he's like
no I'll give you information and then we
fight it out yeah there is excuse me
where is Minister Kotoka you your Lord
go does ninja how convenient of you to
come here I have orders to kill you all
right if I were a soldier
that soldier hanging out by the world
probably on my friend losing a fight
definitely me he's like no stop please
spare my life I will ask you just one
more time where is kataoka musters out
he he
he should be back soon yeah well I made
quick work of that level oh I went the
wrong way I should have gone the roof
but the last fight is coming up here
yeah geez I should use my disguise
enough all right OOP hey he's running
away come on come on I'm close it's
behind this fence minister I never
expected load the Gordana to catch me
kill yourself and show me you still have
some honor yes I will assist you yes way
is called something like that
[Music]
let me assist you know what happens I
will inform law I know that is like a
formal way right it's supposed to be
yeah on a roll like he said but if you
play as a yama the girl character is
like no woman talks to me like that and
then you have to fight him
oh no I hit the retry button seppuku
there we go thank you something along
the lines men why they really like lay
on the disrespect yeah go through a
whole fight start honestly I feel like
it would be even more enjoyable to go
through this as the female character and
just hold that hold that you disrespect
me slice him up can't lose to a woman
that fight
she's got two weapons to shred people I
did the same thing I did the same
mission I forgot I think I might just
die and spawn back to the Select screen
because I pressed retry the mission
again you need that what is this
period-accurate yeah lots of people in
the chat one in a remake or remastered
[Music]
I'd work out perfectly well especially
considering you you know all the Sakura
they're doing well it's like a timeless
genre and I always play as I am II yeah
let me I'll die here those extra boss
battles is all right let me just kill
myself and are kind of back out now just
pseudo coo yourself Richard okay
what's gonna sit down and do my little
puzzle yeah kill me number is in order
wow I could really do a stealth kill any
wouldn't do it couldn't help it damn it
like when you're not trying to be
stealthy
it wasn't me rat your stealth I was
trying to get him to see me oh boy
somebody kill me it's so advanced for
its age yeah I was gonna say this
definitely this is what all the samurai
games hey this guy can kill me who there
I mean please
in theory more please yes very good well
all shoulder buttons Plus start and
select brings you to the main menu we're
not actually on a ps1 so I appreciate
you chat watch is gonna like ruin the
ps3 we're playing like smoke fire
skidding thank you thank you but I don't
know if your progress is still there
yeah we know what I might be um because
I don't want to crap if I may or may not
have to go back to playing as Ricky
Mario because when you pick Ayame you
have to play the levels again and I
don't know if I have a safe stay
let's see that level was called I'll
remember nope I've only played the first
level with her dang it's alright it's
okay speedrun it oh no I can I was just
gonna go back to playing as Ricky Mario
to continue the progress unless you guys
really want to see somebody on a game
play alright next time right there's
always a next time did that one there's
the snow one that I just finished there
we go this level is creepy
ah Jason says I've missed this game so
much
BRB says Persia literally my favorite
one of my favorite games ever says cam
Rogers got you man see we started this
today because uh well eh any reason to
play tenchu am i right
butt beat we have an article up on
GameSpot calm about what our staff is
currently playing you know we always
play the latest and greatest and we
cover gaming news as usual but on our
downtime like what are we playing so we
wrote up an article all about that and
what our staff is playing and this is
what I'm playing on the side so we
decided to stream it today you know what
a great idea right am i right
everyone loves tint you but that
articles full of good ideas from not
good ideas people are playing a little
bit of everything you know all of our
staff very diverse list so if you want
to check it out some GameSpot com
oh here we go look at the little demon
guys that guy with no shirt barely any
pants is gonna try to kill me with fire
you know what this smoke look at that
cut off his little alien arm
oh we just like LeBron James you know
that mean I'm just like this
[Music]
if you appreciate the soundtrack like I
do I know you do you're here for a
reason this game is full of everything
but uh if you're at home rocking out
like LeBron James and me let me know in
the chat like I don't even want to
continue because I just love this song
so much all right let me avoid all this
smother maybe not come on there we go
a demon streaker oh my gosh
fortunately this level is uh actually no
this is not a long level like I thought
it was it's actually pretty sure but I'm
gonna prolong it so we can listen to the
great music versus bang
hi back I'm sorry I drink a lot of
coffee we were just enjoying the music I
was doing a LeBron James dance like this
here we go um that's forget exactly
where I need to go it's been a while I
try I'm selling Persia I try to play
this like every year every other year
because I love this game so much I mean
I'm sure everyone has their reoccurring
game that they always go back to yeah
for a while it was Kingdom Hearts but
yeah
for me it's like this game and Syphon
Filter that's why I wanted to play that
today yeah Kingdom Hearts 2 is
definitely one of those ones for me that
I've replayed probably more than any
other game oh really
in the middle of all this you're like
hello everybody knock knock
I gotta go to that temple all this
blocking I even swung open the door
great okay where's that temple I hear
that crying oh oh you got me again read
by me traces the bonus level in ten
shoot to that time work time warp blue
to modern times is cool I haven't seen
it but that sounds pretty cool
I played tension one infinitely more
times attention to
I'm not gonna lie that was a little
mistake but dude that little flip off of
any wall okay there's the building I
need to go into so I'm on the right
track
come on take a little hop what are you
doing all right there's the boss baby
baby what is the boss right in this
building but these guys will keep
interrupting if I don't kill him last
time whoa whoa whoa all right that arrow
guy he saw me but I can take on an arrow
guy or anything okay I know creepy baby
there with it no I got it
so you're supposed to use a stone to
hurt people I will take it even if it
means gutting you I'm within it there's
another guy here though to really need a
little little space here
oh I'm getting no spacing goodness I
don't need this right now
too close
burn in hell you heretic guys still you
still owe Southtown this is where you
cut it so you're behind this - ray just
sons I'm gone
[Music]
okay oh great there's still another
another enemy in the background oh dang
[Music]
taunting me all right let me get some
space oh my god oh yeah yet no time for
napping david says only cog is the best
villain ever with the best music so can
he can still catch his work yeah this
other guy's got to go my says Oni kaga
means demon shadow oh crap come on
[Music]
there's other guys making me harvest I
wanted Turkey and chances if you die
it's my turn oh so I would have been
dead by now oh maybe one more of these
for a good measure
oh she's gonna kick it out of my hand he
could do this it's so funny to see that
happen also he can use a help to them
whipping it i'm whipping it again
he blocks with his shins tons of steel
you know what we had to see it happen
right
normally that fight isn't so bad
obviously that double axe kick he did
that really got you rekt me I was
blocking you just help you just hold
down to block like a little dramatic
here right they got the whole grave and
everything so Gaiden yeah
I liked the Popoff two from owning cocky
yeah he disgusted with you well we can
just try again definitely help I'm
definitely gonna use these this time I
keep saying I will but I definitely will
this time yeah Anderson is laughing at
my face in the chat that was a that was
a hard L because I was surrounded and I
couldn't hold my own although I tried to
block whatever I tried you threw up an
epic present yes I'm gonna take the
sideways oh you missed the little demon
dudes
[Music]
he's like naked and Evil's fire
he looks like he's enjoying himself yeah
he's vibing then I drew someone he said
like add the thong sign music to his
yeah yeah because he was just dancing
pretty hard I'm gonna void everything
that is hilarious
ultra light it says I remember when this
game had awesome graphics this is like
whoa
people always add those types of cakes
and to babies and stuff now if you like
that graphics are so good I gotta stop
saying I block and blog I didn't use the
damnedest guys again you know okay can i
squirely sneak in here
and pop one of these I want to go in
full health where's your disguise I
guess you don't need it I don't know
oh here like three people oh shoot no
wonder that baby Loki man I can't
welcome you use the stone turn even if
it means cutting you coming on I'm ps5
you while I the trailer for DualShock
controller is that breaking news I shall
investigate in 50
look someone left their baby this simple
yes please retrieve your child or else
we're gonna have to call professionals
okay easy that's me right there baby
he'll burn in hell here comes mr. foot
see oh well at least we get to hear his
song again not this one this one's
pretty funny pretty good but the battle
music with this guy
Oh kick that guy
take a little sip
[Laughter]
oh wow I don't even know if we can get
through all the cutscenes that no nope
oh my gosh didn't know I was gonna read
his yeah didi did more Epson chat I
can't believe it I can't believe it I'm
scrubbing out here mmm
30 minutes you say yeah maybe leave some
of these the smoke helped me out earlier
poisonous rice it works um oh and not
for any congee no I think I think it
might work on bosses that'd be funny
he's like he just loses like 40 points
of his health if he eats it ROM why says
you got him next time bro
appreciate you yeah I've got some rips
in the chat foam oh yeah
here we go
[Music]
it's gonna make it to the castle the
Templar
[Music]
can I find this game in the ps4 store
I'm not sure definitely the ps3 store
under like the PSone classics but I
don't actually I'm not even sure if it's
there that'd be a good question for all
of us to know the answer to all right
there's the temple
trying to research
close I'm gonna take out this guy got
one bow and arrow guys are weak oh shoot
weak we have a small health bar but
these other guys they put a plate for
jumping around oh okay I'm like looking
up tension ps5 and all these hilarious
articles like petition yeah we're just
whipping back and forth me in this guy
there you go oh I have to do this with
one help
I'm just trying to clear out these
little guys first it's so annoying oh
come on see if I can fight those guys
before they come down one was up there
yeah and one was over there
we'll see
hmm someone's sleeping on the job there
is across the map I'm gonna take him out
before he tries to take me out
here's one more
yeah oh shoot now one more Oh
although my health so funny one year it
goes someone playing a forum Kim ps5
lunch with the new Tinchy game please
and the first response was Sakura comes
out next month the same man the
disrespect yeah we don't want this well
we want Sakura of course but we know
it's not tension it's not the same thing
alright there's definitely a guy up here
I'm gonna take him out too
which me like birds I don't know if I
can do all this with no help
I am but one ninja
[Music]
No okay think yeah let's go know what
you want
Stowe best ninja game ever made not
going to get okay you use their Center
on my right yet I will tell you its
final attempt well ty I hope I'm doing
it justice you got a lot of fans out
here
oh my god I don't know if I could do it
now I was sitting back with like my
thumb press so wish me luck burn in hell
you heretic there we go
oh okay yeah Kern says the trailer was
fan-made but that's just the fans really
wanted the guys our way to make this -
come on come on all right
have like half hell wish me luck slow
and steady
yep he's really playing footsies with
you right now I'm scared
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what a way to end it five minutes man I
could also just skip this level because
that's the end of the level
no you gotta do one more time
being a shadow in life in death of
failure yeah yeah I know yeah I can
block right I was blocking I was doing
okay it's strike strike way from to
attack dodge defend strike streak that's
a contest I guess instead of going for
the three hitter just go for the two
hitter cuz he blocked that third hit
anyways he does take some of these
alright we're going out with a bang
y'all all right last one got this this
is Ryu jet so was he hitting you because
your blade was like facing the slightly
off axis maybe because I was blocking
and even I was doing the animation even
for block well actually I can't tell
when you're doing it holding back blocks
but yeah maybe I was just off-kilter and
then yeah hit my shoulder I know the
debug color but Richie's got this oh I
just grappled up a tree
yo quick call an hour
the strategy was good though as far as
like taking out all the little guys it
helped me a lot during the boss fight
but I don't know if I can handle it I'm
a dusty old ninja now there are hips you
cannot block what I don't know if I buy
that friends this guy's got to go this
bow and arrow bozo what system was it
son
Oh bad start you're not that that 10
health points are there those are the
only health we're losing right now I
don't know I can also go around looking
for help boxes this kind of stop maybe I
will let me check this house just as
quick raid
Oh oh my god or I can just get everyone
off my back I hit the tree again
oh this was a mistake fiery breath I
deserve that
Oh turkey says I gotta say thank you for
playing this game and showing some
recognition where it's needed we
appreciate it or at least I do well no
problem literally our pleasure we're
really excited thanks for doing thanks
for saying that that was really nice
any excuse to play this game okay come
on I got time for this don't let up
don't lip oh Shannon chances such
nostalgic getting goose bumps oh man
nice still get that one I played this
game
all right two of them there's a ha yeah
I don't know what to do do I take on
those two guys or just fight them all at
once yeah there's a bow and arrow guy up
here should be pretty weak okay oh well
if I get them off guard then he I can
stealth kill a maybe there you go now
it's a question mark down there where is
he
I just love that but in a music video
games just don't see you very long
enough time and they're like oh like
this was a good technique right there it
might be one more on the other side
might just wing it
oh I missed anyway oh there Ambrose you
use the stone to her we're playing on
the ps3 Junior with the ps1 cutting you
yeah yeah
[Music]
can't get impatient at the end like that
bro
you know that I could do it y'all slow
and steady try to sidestep when you see
someone don't get impatient don't try to
rush him down you've got this oniy
caught it so you're behind this - come
on
damn I'm going into this fight cawing
yes and when the hassle
[Music]
oh go amperes okay okay cornering me
okay too far
lifted miss that entirely I just need
some space that's why I did that on
purpose
I can't tell you how many times I've
done this and it sucks that I'm whipping
it the chat oh come on I blog and that
was not a real fight it cuts off so she
can flip away but chat move by move was
like go back left left go back that's
okay that I got a novice let's end it
there don't leave me hey get yeah well
you guys thank you so much for hanging
out with us happy Monday by the way
starting off the week right with a
little bit of throwback action every
single weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time
is when we go live so come on back now
you hear hope you enjoyed some tin chew
action like we said before we play all
kinds of games we've got all types of
different things going on got content on
the site on the YouTube channel just
everywhere calm for this like the swords
yes they definitely follow us hang out
and we look to you guys next time so
have a good rest of your day don't have
too heavy of a case of Mondays and stay
strong we'll see you guys tomorrow bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you